after ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky said the west sanctions on
russia were not enough to prevent
further russian attacks on his country a
powerful coalition representing some of
the world's biggest democracies
announced it would block some russian
banks from swift
the move was part of a series of severe
economic penalties and it was seen as a
significant step up in the west's
efforts to punish russia and its
president vladimir putin for its
military assault on ukraine the european
union and its partners are working to
[ __ ] putin's ability to finance his
war machine
so what is swift and what does this move
mean for russia and the rest of the
world
swift which stands for the society for
worldwide interbank financial
telecommunication is a global system
that banks use to securely send and
receive transfer requests similar to how
phone networks facilitate calls swift
facilitates the movement of money
the infrastructure is what connects
people together right uh to be able to
talk to each other
this is the same thing for banks it's
simply instead of
ideas and love and messages like that
you're sending on the phone you're
sending money swift handles billions of
financial messages each year and while
there are other systems designed to
circumvent swift and challenge the
dominance of the dollar swift is by far
the most commonly used system around the
world it connects more than 11 000
financial institutions in more than 200
countries and territories headquartered
in belgium swift is a member-owned
cooperative iran and north korea are cut
off from it
so how could swift sanctions impact
russia
by cutting off some russian banks from
the system the sanctions significantly
hinder the movement of money into and
out of russia and that could lead to
higher inflation and a weakening of the
russian ruble it's like you're you're
putting a noose around the pipeline of
of money into and out of russia not only
do the sanctions aim to [ __ ] moscow's
ability to finance the russian military
but they'll also affect every other
aspect of the economy trickling all the
way down to the ability of businesses
and households to move money outside of
the country
the leverage is the leverage on the
economy and the markets that puts
political pressure internally on putin
to to reverse course but swift is a
global network and experts say the
sanctions could have an impact on
countries around the world
foreign banks have about 121 billion in
assets owed to them by russian-based
entities so cutting russian banks off
from swift could make it hard to collect
that money
and companies will undoubtedly face
problems conducting trade with russian
counterparts paying russian staff or
buying goods from russia
however the west is planning for now to
keep some russian banks online for oil
and gas exports critical to the european
and global economies
the you know the willingness
for the west particularly europe
to
accept these economic sacrifices which
are not small right but what that
reflects is the the seriousness they
take russia's actions as a threat to uh
you know western democracy european
democracy post-war world two sort of
agreements